[MUSIC]
Let's start with a quick poll.
Who here is signal?
That's a shocking amount given that
I'm in a room full of really smart and
very attractive people.
We've all seen like pretty woman.
These movies have one message.
That one for you is out there and
fate will help you find them, really?
I love love.
Love to me is the most
powerful drug in the world.
Love feels like magic.
Love drives some of us
a little bit insane, but
let's be real in order to find love,
we need to be strategic.
And strategies my thing,
I am the definition of a career woman.
When I was 12 years old,
I started working as a carpenter.
I made $12 an hour and I felt tremendous.
From there on I was hooked.
I worked my way up into construction
industry leading multimillion dollar
projects and
my life was only about career.
Money was freedom.
Then one Sunday afternoon,
I land in Berlin excited to get back
to work when life decided
to throw me a curveball.
I had a missed call from my.
And when I called back, I learned that
my pap smear had come back positive.
At age 25,
I was diagnosed with cervical cancer.
When I called the doctor back,
she asked me a simple question, Sarah,
do you want to have children?
If not, they will do a one time surgery
that removes the cancer forever.
If yes, they had to do a small surgery,
with a 20% risk of the cancer coming back.
Confronting this a strong,
independent Korean woman in
her mid 20s felt impossible.
I fell into a hole of self reflection, I
had money, but I might never have family.
Was there more out there
in life than just career?
The good news is that I hold a PhD
in Data Science and Engineering and
therefore I decided to not rely on fate
when it comes to figure out that question.
So in very much me fashion, I went all in.
In the year,
I did real life experiments, and
I ended up going on 100
dates with 100 people.
Yeah, it was a lot of work.
Four years and two serious long and
happy relationships.
Later, I have two empirical learnings
that I'm going to share with you today.
First, input equals output.
Yes, we've all heard this,
it's done for business school, but
it's also very much true
when it comes to dating.
Dating is a part time job.
However, since we're little children,
we spend 40 plus hours a week advancing
our careers learning from generations of
generations who have done this before, and
everything in order to make more money.
However, enough research shows that if
you want to live a long, happy, and
fulfilled life, it's not really
about how much money you make.
It's all about relationships.
So why do we not focus on
what matters most to us?
Why do we not learn about it?
If I had to rewrite my Stanford essay
now about what matters most to me and
why, I would probably write about love.
And let's be real, I would probably
not be here today with you.
Second big learning.
A long term partner is way more
like a business partner and
a best friend than somebody
we have a spark with.
And don't get me wrong, I love the spark.
Spark is great.
However, I'm arguing to
look behind the spark and
figure out if long term interests and
values actually align instead of just
relying on an initial chemical connection.
When I had my two empirical learnings
given that I'm a scientist,
I decided maybe there's
real research out there.
So I went down a rabbit hole of
reading every research paper that has
ever been written about dating and love.
And I put it all together into something
that I call an informal PhD in dating.
So I ended up writing a dating book
called Startup Your Love Life,
where I apply business knowledge and
data analysis on finding a life partner.
And yes, you can buy it now on Amazon.
I brought some of the most important
insights here with me today for you.
But first, let's take a step back.
We were talking about Julia Roberts and
Richard Gere.
They meet each other randomly and
fall deeply in love.
What a great story.
But how likely is that
the odds of finding love
randomly are 1 to 562-0.17%.
It is five times more likely that your
next bottle of wine is going to cork.
We spend an average about a 10th on the
time we spend on choosing the right career
on choosing the right partner, and from
going to date to actually having a baby.
It takes an average seven years in the US.
So how can we make the odds
a little bit more likely?
And how can we make this whole
process a little bit more efficient?
We need to use business knowledge.
And yes, we're in business school,
so let's do that.
When you start a new business, the first
thing you should think about is do your
research and development and
decide what market you're going after.
In business terms,
we call this total addressable market.
Short TAM.
So let's do this for me,
as a dating product.
My time is as follows.
I'm looking for
a man 50% of the market, aged 30 to 37.
Six feet or taller, only 9% of the market,
with a bachelor's degree and
similarly attractive, and
max 50 miles from here.
The time for
me as a dating product is 223 men.
That's not big.
If I'm willing to go down to 511 or
taller, my time goes up to 450 men.
Still not big, but doable.
After you do your research and
development and decide on your time,
the next step in every startup process
is to decide on your sales strategy.
The good thing is when it comes to dating,
there's only three big sales strategies
that captured 90% of the market.
You can date in bars and restaurants,
you can date on dating apps, or
you can date through friends of friends.
And every good investor in the room will
have the same question for me right now.
Sara, what's the return of
investment of all of that?
The return of investment or also ROI for
these three sales
strategies is as follows.
If you date in bars and
restaurants the ROI is you need to meet
about 90 people to get one actual match.
The ROI of dating apps is you need
to match with 60 people to get one
real potential candidate.
And the ROI of dating through friends
of friends is about 30 people to 1.
Yes, you're smart enough.
We should all date through
friends of friends After you have
figured out your sales strategies, the
next step in your startup process is you
need to do some piloting and
figure out if you have product market fit.
And product market fit and
dating is really when you found somebody,
you hopefully like but also where you
don't have any serious deal breaker quiz.
So in order to get there you need to
decide on your deal breakers versus your
nice to haves.
Write those deal breakers down,
screen for them early and
do not compromise because you
probably get hurt down the road.
And yes, I know of some people who
keep track of the deal breakers
in Excel spreadsheets, so
they have weekly KPIs.
Next step in your dating
journey is marketing.
And the good news is
when it comes to dating,
marketing is really all about
optimizing your dating profile.
And there's a lot of research about this.
First, when you take pictures for
your dating profile,
take them from the left of your face,
not from the right, why?
Because through an art history,
we have developed an inherent bias towards
seeing beautiful faces from the left and
not from the right things to
people like Leonardo da Vinci.
Second, if you're a guy and
you think sunglasses or whatever kind
of other glasses will do the trick,
get rid of them, you lose 15% of swipes.
And yes, if you have a picture
of you from that last wedding or
whatever the picture with formal wear,
put it on your dating profile.
Because you score higher on
trustworthiness and influence.
And yes, you need a picture with a pet,
preferably dog.
So go out there, steal your neighbor's
dog, take a picture with it and
put it on your dating profile, because
you'll score higher on date ability.
And lastly, if you're a man,
we're bright colors, and
if you're a woman, we're red,
and you're going to crush it.
I'm telling you all of
this to give you hope.
There is research out there that we can
leverage to make dating more efficient,
and ultimately more enjoyable.
Business is not magic.
Businesses strategy.
Love is not magic either.
It's more like a magic trick.
So look behind the curtain, figure out
what's actually going on and treat it more
like your career than like something
that will randomly happen to you.
Make magic happen.
After having researched dating for several
years, I have the toolkit, the scientific
formula for love and the conviction to
build a real family while having a career.
Luckily, I am now cancer free,
and I can still have children.
Have I found the right partner yet?
No, not yet.
I might have to rethink some of
my deal breakers in my time.
But I know that by putting in the work and
using strategy,
I will find a co founder for
my life so that we can IPO our love.
And given last week's KPIs and funnel
data, I think I'm slowly getting there.
So, instead of waiting for
Richard Gere to drive by this limo,
go make strategy your copilot.
Get into the driver's seat yourself and
start up your love life.